full anime are you in this i am double
mr anthony mackie that's hard as [ __ ]
yeah yeah
i did kick a buddy in the face
hey guys we
we're back
stuntmen react we have a special guest
today aaron tony
today guys it's super exciting to have
you here thank you uh just give us a
little bit about what stuff you've been
in i've got probably about 15 years in
the business i've worked on everything
from power rangers to pirates of the
caribbean so guys we got a lot of
awesome clips today let's just jump in
he's not hitting the police
oh yes are you in this i am double mr
anthony mackey
[Music]
we have good memories about this scene
and we were killing people we were just
killing people
hey
oh i got him
yeah what is that a jumping spinning
back kick that is a jump spinning back
kick yes sir it looks so good that's
awesome yeah that was fun we were on a
wire and i had one placed in the front
and the back and um the costume is not
the lightest it's made out of cordura
cordura is a type of military spec
fabric that does not tear so a lot of
the costumes is made out of that the
wings are cg um but i am wearing a
rubberized backpack when we did this we
did probably three solid takes and he's
being ratcheted so it's me making
contact with him but as soon as i even
just tap
he's gone yeah that's really good timing
between you know the performer and the
stunt riggers and we had some of the
best in the business that's michael
huggins crew and i love working with
those guys those guys are amazing so in
the original sort of rehearsals i kicked
the the guy in in the face i didn't kick
this guy
but i did kick a buddy in the face and
every time i'm on set when i i work with
this group guys they always haze me
about it like remember that time you
kicked so and so in the face i'm like
yes i remember you remember that time i
asked to have a taller guy
[Laughter]
what the hell is that
got a gimmick now
see ya
this was a scene that we all had to keep
really hush-hush about we were shooting
probably two to three months and there
was murmurs and everybody was like don't
say anything you say nothing because you
know we're not sure if it's going to
happen but we got the word that we were
getting spider-man and we all knew it
and we couldn't say anything to anybody
that scene in particularly when i went
to to go ahead and tackle i tackled
nothing
i literally they were just like hey
you're going to go and you're just going
to make your arms and make sure that you
don't close them because you're going to
tackle them and then you're going to
take over so that's exactly what we did
for that scene but we did have time
there to run dialogue sometimes set up
for for eye eye lines and such all right
sorry my bad
[Music]
that that was fun
painful
with this shot we actually you can't see
it now but there was a huge high dense
mat that they set up for us we were on
wires that helped descend us into the
actual floor how close did your head
come to the escalator was it actually
that close or was it added later clint
i'm glad you asked that question because
i literally like we did it and it was on
our last takes my buddy came up to me
and he was like hey man are you okay and
i'm like yeah man i'm good man he looked
at me like he was white and he was like
i had a heart attack i thought you hit
your head and i looked back and i was
like oh i'm in it this is all practical
so i i almost clipped my head on the
very last take it's true yeah wow
[Music]
oh what an amazing scene like i worked
on this and i still go oh that's so cool
i love it this was months and they built
an actual tarmac and that tarmac we were
shooting out there in summer oh that was
very hot it was so hot um poor a poor
ghee was in the black panther suit and i
remember coming up to him because he had
his harness on and he was cinched in and
he i just see him he was like ready to
pass out and i was like buddy are you
okay you needed some water
[Music]
oh man
we we all knew about this scene too can
i talk about bad cg yeah
[Music]
what is going on my legs
every time i see that he's like
that's a leg replacement it's it's it's
not even me that's not even me or mackie
that is full cg falcon until he's
standing there whenever i did landings i
would always try to like think of
parachute guys like they always tuck up
and land and i sometimes would get flat
from people about they're like don't
tuck up the legs and so when i see that
i'm like that's better that's better to
you for him to wiggle his legs like that
you got to be get out of here
i'm
sorry this part we get ratcheted
straight back how do you just how do you
not just smack your head on the ground
the backpack helps so as soon as i'm
going that backpack i'm like all right i
know i'm going i'm going to go ahead and
assess typically don't put your hands
down but i went so far i was like nope
i'm gonna go engage okay tap and roll so
i didn't smack my head as soon as i hit
the ground i was like okay i'm good and
i just kind of rolled over my neck on my
head softly on the grass weight is a
factor with ratchets like this so if you
are wearing a costume that's a little
top-heavy sometimes it's better to be
picked a little bit lower or higher
depending on how heavy your actual legs
are so for me they're like we're gonna
pick you here now if i do that
i would have kind of went ass over tea
kettle and smacked my head oh so that
that was a personal preference and
that's talking
with your riggers about how how do you
want to ride this it's a collaboration
yeah as it should great
guys go ahead and subscribe because we
got a lot of different react series in
the works we have construction workers
react orthodontists react morticians
react we have monkeys react to andy
circus
so go ahead and subscribe for all those
great shows coming
out so much emotion in this fight scene
oh a lot so i know both of the doubles
who worked worked on this you had khalid
gajiri
and then you had kofi yadon i did double
michael on reshoots and when i had to
put the dots on yeah it was uh probably
like like maybe
six or seven appliances and i'm like
this man does this every day but it's
nice that they don't have to plan like
you know just dot for dot they literally
had had appliances that they put on like
a whole sheet that like just oh
interesting yeah this fight is really
really cool though it's just intense you
know it's not like a lot of flipping
it's more heart the fight coordinator
jonathan eusebio his team and himself
they used a lot of capoeira
which is a brazilian martial art they
used c-lot uh there's there's tray
traces of that in in the fights as well
and this is a lot of the actors actually
doing this and these guys did an amazing
job i'd agree like so many times when
the actors do it it looks so janky yeah
so janky like you actually have to put
in the work to make it look good and you
can tell here that these guys did that
yeah you know and and both of them um
mike and chadwick are exceptional
athletes i remember working with mike
for reshoots and he was really good
about picking up choreography quick i
feel like there's actors out there that
are really good and when they understand
the intent behind the movement
everything else is easy i see a lot of
stunt people that come in and they go
and run run through the fight and
they're okay they're just kind of like i
just gotta remember the moves and then
when you get an actor and they go okay
well what am i do am i selling this am
am i hurt here already actors will go
ahead and play up extra things that you
didn't even think about maybe he's he's
playing when he he gets hit in the
stomach he's playing to a gunshot shot
wound that he had so he rested a little
longer before he goes back into the
fight that to me is a sign of a good
performer because those things you're
telling the story through the action
that's always important and so i always
hold hold of that when i do anything you
are a performer first you're not just a
stunt person you're an actual stunt
performer i like to say
[Music]
i worked on a movie called tom yum
you worked on that i worked on that i
doubled latif crowder for that fight
just through the tail end of that fight
latif um hurt his achilles and so he
couldn't finish the fight so flew me in
i had to go and eat a bunch of food and
gain gain weight i still didn't get as
big as latif but i finished that whole
fight
this is the capoeira
yeah you're freaking eddie gordo
look at the speed on the man this is
probably one of the best actual capoeira
fights in history and the way it it's
being used like everything is that it
has function purpose he makes it look so
easy that's hard as [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
but he just makes it like it's like no
big deal yeah like i'm just gonna bounce
on my hands that's easy you show off
so right here he does what's called a au
batido switch
[Music]
oh wow so you ended up like uh pulling
his uh achilles he said yeah he ruptured
it when he back tucked in punch fronted
apparently it just he did a couple of
them and he landed but if he was done
after that and then this is all me you
see how that's you right there yeah you
see how skinny he got
so the moment they swap out you just get
your butt kicked yeah i'm just his ass
[Music]
he hit me on that but they they used a
different tank okay literally 7 20 kicks
me in the face and he had a padded shoe
on and it was the first time that i had
seen that they they took his converse
shoe and they put a big piece of just
high dense foam on the bottom and he'd
went full send on his on his kick and i
just remember i on one of them i kind of
blacked out for a second and came back
it was like i'm going down no i'm okay
i'm okay i'm okay
it's interesting they don't hold the
slow motion for the full contact i don't
know why they didn't i don't know it was
weird and look i walked the walk out
it's the worst ending i was like uh
it's the worst ending ever but that
fight is still boss tony god is best man
so when doing full contact hits the he's
not pulling it at all or he has to a
little bit like a little bit there's got
to be a little bit of an art to it not
just beating the crap out of your dudes
or is that just so there's two different
ways to go ahead and stack a hit
sometimes you're getting plowed through
it depends on where you're getting hit
at so say if you're taking a hit to like
like the chest sometimes with what
they'll do is you'll either pad up or
you won't pad up and literally it's more
of a sort of it's more of a direct sort
of push through as opposed to if i went
like that you feel that more if i do
that at full full force you're gonna
feel that but if i go like this and push
that's better and that's something
that's attributed to like when you when
you train in like martial arts so you
train a martial let's learn how to go
ahead and pull your power so it's really
important and that that's what you know
someone like tony jaw excels at if you
guys have a cool action scene or a fight
scene or a crazy stunt doesn't even have
to be from a movie can be from anything
please leave a suggestion down in the
comment section below
[Music]
yeah this is mine um i i directed this
it's called throne there's some solid
wesley snipes going on yeah definitely
definitely yeah
wait who do you recognize
who do you recognize oh i know that guy
oh wait i know him on the left andy andy
andy and brian
malaya's in there yeah we've got a bunch
of all-stars
oh
[Laughter]
dude that's rad i'm i'm a huge soul
calibur fan so i was like a buddy of
mine was like he was like you should do
sword trails and i was like you're right
so so chris cowan shot that did that
that course he did of course he did that
is a chris cowan shot man i was like
calling put your sauce on it bro and he
did it
dude i love your choreography it's
awesome thanks brother i appreciate it
if people wanted to go see that short
film where would they go to see it they
would go to my youtube page erin tony
and you can see that you can see primal
and i've done little viral things like
the fight challenge you started that i
did
wow
dude stunt man fight choreographer meme
lord who were
[Laughter]
[Music]
one two three
[Applause]
i've been finding myself the bottom line
is equality
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
aaron your insights are awesome i love
your attitude with how you approach
stunts and like the art like your
passion clearly shines through here i
love this business yeah
i appreciate you guys like i've watched
you guys for years you know what's funny
i'll have to admit this i don't
subscribe but i watch all your stuff i'm
sorry okay i will subscribe now he's one
of them i'm one of them he's like he's
watching everything but he's not
subscribing what a jerk i will now okay
damn it i will you wanna play some smash
bros heck yeah all right let's go let's
go